the judge also made it clear that it was
important to her that these sentences
are not only punishments but that they
are act as a deterrent to other parents
who might be tempted to do something
criminal like this do you think they are
I think anybody who has watched this
case has seen the public humiliation the
personal shame the sentences that are
being handed out and I hope it's a
wake-up call to anybody out there that
yes college is important but there are a
lot of good schools out there and your
kids are going to be fine
if you let them you'll go through the
process and have faith that they'll find
a place that works for them do you think
this scandal is a symptom of the
stresses of college and mission and the
whole process there or is this really
does it come down to affluent people
just breaking the rules to the advantage
of their own children there's broader
issues around the college admissions
process that I frankly am NOT an expert
on this conduct clearly crossed the line
but it's all part of gaming the system
some of it legally some of it out in the
open some of a transparent this not and
that's why it crossed the line into
criminal conduct but I think there's a
lot of aspects of the college admissions
system that I hope get revisited coming
out of a case like this